hi this is presh talwalkar
warren buffett once challenged bill
gates to a special dice game like the
following
the dice each had six faces that were
equally likely to show up but the
numbers were different than a standard
dice
one of the dice had all threes on all of
its six faces
another one had zero on two of its faces
and four on four of its faces
a third dice had an equal number of ones
and fives
and a fourth dice had two on four's
faces and six on two of its faces
so here's how the game works you and i
are each going to pick a different one
of these dice we're not going to pick
the same ones we're going to pick
different dice
we're then going to roll against each
other and the person who rolls a higher
number gets a point
we then repeat that many many times so
that the person who rolls the highest
number of points over many roles is
going to win the game
i'm going to graciously offer you to let
you pick your die first which one do you
want
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
so let's analyze this game suppose you
pick the dice that has all threes
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
pick the dice which has zero on two of
its faces and four on four of its faces
what's going to happen when we roll
against each other
well if i roll a zero which happens two
out of the six times i'm gonna lose to
you because you're always gonna roll a
three
however
in the four out of the six times that i
roll a four i'm actually going to beat
you
so i'm going to beat you two-thirds of
the time so if you pick a dice which has
all threes you're gonna lose to me
two-thirds of the time
so now suppose you know this strategy
and you say well why don't i pick the
dice that has two zeros and four fours
well if you're going to pick that dice
then i'm going to go ahead and pick the
dice which has
three ones and three fives
it's a little harder to analyze what
happens when we roll these two dice
against each other but it's not too
complicated
now i'm going to win if i roll a five
because any time i roll a five it's
higher than you rolling a zero or a four
so in three out of the six cases i'm
going to roll a five and i'm guaranteed
to win
now when i roll the one in three out of
the six cases
i'm only going to beat you in the two
out of six cases that you roll a zero as
well
so in summary
i'm going to win 3 6 times 1 when i roll
a 5 plus 3 6 when i roll a 0 when i roll
the 1 times 2 6 when you roll a zero
so this nets out to two thirds of the
time i'm going to win so once again your
die that you pick is going to lose to my
die two-thirds of the time
this argument continues let's suppose
you picked the die that i just had well
in that case i'm going to pick the next
die which has
two on four of his faces and six on two
of his faces we can do a similar
calculation i'm going to win 2 out of
the 6 times when i roll a 6 guaranteed
and i'm also going to win if i roll a 2
which is 4 6 of the time against your 1
which happens 3 6 of the time
so once again i'm going to beat your die
two-thirds of the time
finally you say all right i'll pick the
die you just had and then i'm going to
go ahead and say well i'm going to pick
the die that has all threes now i'm
going to win whenever i roll
whenever you roll a 2 which happens 4 6
of the time so once again your die is
losing to my die two-thirds of the time
so what we've shown
is that each die is actually going to
lose two-thirds of the time to another
die
and this is what's known as
non-transitive dice
each die can be beaten like another like
a game of rock paper scissors this is a
cyclical game and that's why it's
non-transitive
the first person who selects the die is
always going to be at a disadvantage to
someone who picks this second because
each die can be beaten by another
as the story goes warren buffett
challenged bill gates to this and said
go ahead why don't you select first
bill gates was smart enough to say let
me inspect the dice and he figured out
that there was something weird going on
with the dice
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description